Jameer is training for race and is
running laps around the field if the
distance around the field is 300 yards
how many complete laps would he need to
do to run at least at least two miles so
with they tell us how far one lap is
this 300 yards but we need to figure out
how many laps to go two miles so a good
starting point where to get everything
into the same units we have distance
here in terms of miles we have it here
in terms of yards so let's just get
everything into yards so he needs to run
two miles so two miles how do we convert
that to yards well I don't have it
memorized how many yards there are per
mile but I do have it memorized how many
feet there are per mile and it's a good
thing to have in the back of your brain
someplace that in general you have 5,280
feet per mile it's a good number to know
5,280 feet per mile so if we want to
convert we could first convert the miles
to feet and then we know that there are
three feet per yard and then we'll have
two miles in terms of yards so two miles
if we want it converted to feet we want
miles in the denominator so you want
miles in the denominator and we want
feet in the numerator and the reason why
I say that is so that this miles will
cancel out with that miles and we'll
just have feet there and we I just wrote
down there's 5280 5,280 feet per mile or
you say 5,280 feet for every one mile
you could write it either way but let's
just write it like that and then we
could multiply so this is going to give
us what if we just multiply the numbers
two times 5,280 so what is that going to
be maybe I should get a calculator out
but we could do that in our head
two times 5,000 let's think of it this
way two times eighty is 162 times 200 is
400 so it's going to be 400 plus 100x T
is going to be 560 and then two times
5,000 is 10,000 so it's 10,000 10,000
560 and then the miles cancel out and
then the miles cancel out and we are
just we are just left with
and maybe let me actually multiply it
out I did it in my head that time but
that's not always used so let me verify
for you
that 5,280 times two is indeed 10,000
560 so 2 times 0 is 0 2 times 8 is 16
carry the 1 2 times 2 is 4 plus 1 is 5 2
times 5 is 10 10,000 560 so he needs to
run 10,000 560 feet now we want this in
terms we want this in terms of yards so
10,000 560 feet let's convert this to
yards well we wanted in yards so we want
yards in the numerator we want yards in
the numerator and we want feet in the
denominator so that the feet cancel out
with that feet right there and we know
that there are 3 feet for every one yard
3 feet for every 1 yard or another way
to read this is that you have 1/3 of a
yard for every foot and now we can
multiply and it makes sense if you're
going from feet to yards the number
should get smaller because yards is a
bigger unit you need fewer yards to go
the same distance as a certain number of
feet so it makes sense that we're
dividing same thing 2 miles is a ton of
feed so it made sense that we were
multiplying by a large number here it
makes sense that we're dividing so let's
do this so this becomes 10,500 60 times
1/3 so it's 10,000 560 over 3 that's
that in that part and then the feet
cancel out and we're just left with we
are just left with yards so this is 210
2 miles is five thousand ten thousand
five hundred and sixty divided by three
and let's figure out what that is so 3
goes into 10,000 560 it goes into
doesn't go into one it goes into 10
three times three times three is nine
and we subtract we get one bring down
this five comes to 15 3 goes into 15
five times five times three is
fifteen we have no remainder or Giro you
bring down the 6 3 goes into 6 two times
let me scroll down a little bit
2 times 3 is 6 subtract no remainder
bring down this last 0 3 goes into 0 0
times 0 times 3 is 0 and we have no
remainder so this is going to be so two
miles is equivalent to three thousand
five hundred and twenty yards three
thousand five hundred and twenty yards
that's the total distance he has to
travel that's the equivalent of 2 miles
now we want to figure out how many laps
there are we want this in terms of laps
not in terms of yards so we want the
yards to cancel out we want the yards to
cancel out and we want elapsed in the
numerator right because when you
multiply the yards will cancel out it
will just be left with laps now how many
laps are there per yard or yards per lap
well they say the distance around the
field is 300 yards so we have 300 yards
for every one lap so now if we multiply
this right here the yards will cancel
out and we will get three thousand five
hundred and twenty let me do that in a
different color we will get three
thousand five hundred and twenty that
right there times one over three hundred
when you multiply times one it just
becomes three thousand five hundred
twenty divided by three hundred and in
terms of the units the yards cancelled
out we're just left with the laps so
this is how many laps he needs to run so
three thousand five hundred twenty
divided by three hundred well we can
eyeball this right here what is 11 times
three hundred let's just approximate
this right here so if we did 11 times
three hundred eleven times three hundred
what is that going to be equal to well
11 times 3 is 33 and then we have two
zeroes here so this will be 3,300 so
it's a little bit smaller than that if
we have 12 times 300 what is that going
to be 12 times 3 is 36 and then we have
these two zero
so it's equal to 3600 so this is going
to be 11 point something it's larger
than 11 right 35 20 is larger than 3,300
so when you divide by 300 you're going
to get something larger than 11 but this
number right here is smaller than 3600
so when you divide it by 300 you're
gonna get something a little bit smaller
than 12 so the exact number of laps is
going to be a little bit lower than 12
laps so 2 miles is a little bit lower
than 12 laps but let's make sure we're
answering their question how many
complete laps
how many complete laps would he need to
do to run at least 2 miles so they're
telling us that look you know this might
be I don't know 11 point something
something something laps and that would
be the exact number of laps to run 2
miles but they say how many complete
laps does he have to run 11 complete
laps would not be enough he would have
to run 12 so our answer here is 12
complete 12 complete laps that complete
tells us that they want a whole number
of laps we can't just divide this we
divide this we're going to get some 11
points something something you can do it
with the calculator or do it by hand if
you're interested but we have to do at
least 12 because that's our that's the
the smallest whole number of laps that
will get us to at least this distance
right here or this number of laps or the
equivalent of 2 miles